hi and welcome to the corridor cast
today's guest is Freddie long Freddie in
us we go way back
because Freddie actually lived with us
back in the early days before YouTube
back in like 2008 2009 and 2010 so when
his career launched so did ours me we
grew up side by side on the internet
watching the world change before us and
influencing the platform that you guys
know today is YouTube now also freddie
and sam pretty think Sam is like the
funniest guy in the world and so I
expect some good sparks to fly in this
podcast
it's gonna be a good one we're gonna
talk about what Freddie's up to these
days his quirky hobbies that he has why
there aren't a lot of videos going up on
a rocket jump what happened to vGHS
season four well there wasn't actually a
season four but why wasn't there a
season for all these great questions and
more on the corridor cast sit back relax
stay tuned literally it was Father's Day
I think a year ago and I was hanging out
with Anthony Anthony Burch who writer of
video games comic books and and has
worked on some of our stuff like Rakesh
on the show and we were talking bout D&D
and we're time o week fun to like get
our friends together do a podcast do a
thing and we just in the course of
conversation we realized that every dad
archetype is a D&D archetype because
we're like yeah like if your dad is like
a soft rock cover band dad well then
that's a bard if your dad's a stepdad
who doesn't ever you know come home and
it's like a wayward debt that's a rogue
joking about and like if you're joking
about like dad archetypes working or
like what if we did I guess we call the
dungeons and daddys all right that's not
a BDSM five gasps but if you do five
guys and it's about like dads in our
world there's like a whole sub-genre of
this stuff but like dads in our world
who get transported into the deity like
Forgotten Realms of world but they're
just real dads in our world with real
objects from our world and they have to
rescue their sons because they're bad
dads and then you learn about being good
dads are you I'm so I my character's
name is Glenn Close
yeah and I'm right now a level-two bard
which in an inn can and I have a rock
cover band the Glenn Close trio and so
it's a lot of fun it's it's it's me as
Matan will beth mae who's done the last
stuff on other podcast story break and
then anthony's DMing it and yeah it's
called dodges and daddys and that's what
we've been that's like the thing that
I've been doing a lot of right now we've
been doing that for not that long it's
only been about a month we even your big
podcast guy right you have you have
story break you have now you're done I
just have to that's that's that's okay
they only if you heard the joke whether
you call a collection what do you call
collection of like crows my murder of
gross right geese flock what do you call
a collection of three guys in Los
Angeles but yeah but yeah it's been fun
it's it's fun doing like getting more
into like audio editing and sort of that
stuff because it's a heavy sort of thing
and one here's a weird thing that I
found when we were recording these D&D
sessions everyone has lag like you'll do
a thing where it's like every because
everyone's trying to like be in
character and react to the roles and
stuff so when you listen to a
conversation there's like no I measured
it like 250 to 300 milliseconds of lag
as you process what's going on convert
into your character and then respond
back in character then when you're
playing it you don't notice it but I
mean listen you're like what has
everyone pausing like in between
everything they say like oh it's it's
lag it's funny in character lag
that's incredible you have a lot of
interesting hobbies you know I think I
think it's because I get bored easily
Nico is that what it is I think so
stillness or the universe creeping
around you well no because I
okay let me ask you this guys the
everyone's like desert island what would
you do to entertain yourself what would
you do that entertain yourself yeah
desert got nothing around you sam
castles sand castles is pretty good you
got you you get really good imagine if
Tom Hanks instead of right doing all his
[ __ ] was like I'm gonna go I'm gonna
get really good at sandcastles
that's the truth of it Oh what you
saying what would you be doing that
desert island I was like I'd be like
using coconuts for bongo drums and I'm
humming until I with her away that's a
good image I feel like I could I feel
like I was like I was like I bet you I
could amuse myself in very I bet you
don't get really good at beatboxing
that's what I'm saying that was a feat
boxing number one don't need people do
not want to practice with people around
you like you can't beat boxing is a
private affair in your own bathroom in
your own time if anyone's around you're
gonna get out right is this is a segue
into you know this is a great setup if
we just like drop on us that you have
got a really good you wish Niko no no
I'm not gonna be boxing but and but then
I wonder too it's like it's a useless
skill like I think I feel like over the
course of my life I've collected a good
number of useless skills beatboxing was
definitely in that category
wait wait you said you have collected
that's good no no no I'm saying would be
in that category right well I mean it's
basically it allows you to busk anywhere
in the world that's true it is like the
ultimate busking tool yeah just walk up
ya put you put a hat down and go for it
you need a mic because Ravi boxing is a
little bit okay so Charlie right you
need them the mic is really what brings
the performance out of it's true you
that bass yeah and then the moment you
have a loop pedal all of a sudden she's
like cool go anywhere what's the most
impressive busker you've ever seen um
like who's someone that you've actually
stopped and be like where's my wall I
need so I guess he was asking at the
time but never sexy sax man he's not the
one I'm talking about but you remember
his sexy I do remember sexy sax yeah
yeah who could forget those gyrating
hips and dulcet tones so I mean I ended
up going to this like performance like
the small like art house performance
that he and a couple of the musicians
were playing it and and there's this
other guy I think it was Corey Jamal
mm-hm
and he was a busker on Santa Monica and
like it was in this like small concrete
apartment room but like the crew sticks
were really good because of that yeah
and he was insane that's awesome yeah
that's the best busker I've ever and you
saw him in like a performative contact
yeah do you think you
the stopped on the street if you heard
him like Waylon I like stopping for
buskers but yeah me too yeah nobody else
really when people feel self-conscious
about it whether like oh if I stop I
feel like obligated to pay it's like
well yeah sure just throw some throw
some coins in man like you some change
on you you know yeah what you say I mean
you know I it's it's weird like I would
say it's it's more like my my favorite
busker but it's my favorite busking
instrument and usually it's like a
saxophone and essentially I like if
you're a good sax player on the street
like you can you can you can play a lot
of great songs but the problem it's like
it's too piercing it's like you you
wanna it's not like you're there for a
performance you know you're going about
your business you're not at the concert
ya know so it's like I feel like a
dulcimer like a hammered dulcimer like a
weird but a nice slab of sound in the
Renaissance Fair something that's like a
little lighter and tenure and kind of
like kind of blends into the the ambient
sound scape it's like I want to
soundtrack to my life not not you know I
don't want ya to a show yeah and as you
walk by it has to be like is that
welcome to the jungle and then you're
stopped and then you're a teen solo from
yeah exactly
yeah friebert um so the most impressive
busker I've ever seen was in Denver
Colorado and the Denver I guess is well
known for buskers and this guy was
called the zipcode man and no joke you
would walk up to him and he I he Beck
what's your zip code and you tell him
his zip code and he Beck oh you live and
he would tell you where you were and
anybody like around the world who but
you're here yeah oh you're from here and
I was like okay that's impressive enough
for a but as a feat of memory but like
again zip codes can get very specific
right cuz like you know here in LA like
just in downtown there's like you know a
bunch of numbers for just even like the
downtown area yeah he was specific
enough to be able to tell you you must
be near this cross street and the
craziest was an Israeli woman walked up
and she said like and she said she said
her zip code and he was like oh you're
from Israel you're in this neighborhood
and then he the third level he was like
is this Peter shop still there I love
this place this is a [ __ ] it's I live
like three doors down from I love that
spot it's amazing that's like
like beer like Howard not only was he
able to know where you were he was able
to have like a little factoid about like
your region and he was like yeah because
like I talked to people and if I ever
hear is if code I don't know I asked him
about it and then I now have that zip
code in my memory hands like the most
impressive thing about it was really he
doesn't have like an earbud or something
no just he just memorized and that his
whole thing is just he just no zip codes
it reminds me of when I went to
Universal Studios and like one of the
like in character like guides
informational people like was giving us
a little row no like here's the map
here's a park these are the good rides
so where you guys from and were like
well we're living in LA but we're
actually from Minnesota so yeah we're
about it's like so I was like oh yeah do
you guys ever go across the river to
that one bar that's you know on Sundays
when they don't sell liquor in Minnesota
because that one right over there in
Bayport and we're not bayport but
Somerset were like same deal I guess
maybe zip code guy got a job at
Universal for the summer Navy maybe that
I guess what I guess zip code guy tells
us is that in this day this modern day
the most impressive thing you can do is
just have a mediocre memory cuz you read
about guys back in like the medieval
times any big these monks memorize these
books like people were able to like have
multiple languages under their belt and
be able to recite whole passages from
you know poetry and also just because
everyone was exercising that muscle
because they needed to yeah and a lot of
ways right technologies allow this to
externalize our need for memory so as a
result anybody who's just like good if
you can just if you just remember
someone's phone number on the top of
your dome you're all your [ __ ] Berlin
yeah already right these nine digits
belong to you so how did you he's 10
digits no wait 9 wait 10 number you
could be Merlin if you just practice
memorizing people's people's phone
numbers ready what's your mom's phone
number do you remember it I do remember
my mom's phone I remember Jimmy's phone
number I remember Jimmy's phone number I
remember my mom's phone number and my
dad's phone number and I remember two
more my old house phone number when
growing up and my best friends houses
folk when I was growing up you still
have those right I think I need a phone
so I can just because it's a pattern
memory thing right I had a friend who
little bit of music in there too yeah
yeah
I had a friend who's his number was just
right down the middle oh it was like it
was a game she's not this anymore and
but like it was like two eight five two
five eight it was just like that it was
like that's cool nobody gives a [ __ ]
about nobody cares about cool numbers
now cuz you just live in the you live in
someone's contacts I wish again I wish I
had the ability to just be able to pull
no because like again that may be even
more impressive than knowing people's
names I have a friend who actually can
do that you know the people who have
I've met in my life who are the most
like politically adept are people who
can recall your name like right when
they meet you and there's no like yeah
what's up dude hey man let me introduce
you to my friends so that will tell you
exactly right and and by the way god
bless the people who like can feel that
out and be like and like somehow work
themselves in third person in an
anecdote about themselves into your this
conversation so you remember it's like
oh you don't remember me let me just
work my name into this conversation for
you so I'm a friend who's very good at
that I was like dude how do you do that
he's like you want about the secret is I
know I was like every time I meet
someone new I like get a picture with
them or something like that where I find
them on Facebook I have a Google Doc
that is everybody I'm meeting and I
drill myself every night 20 minutes
before I go to bed flashcards and I'm
like this person and in some cases if
it's like important for my job like I'll
have like a little note like oh they
have a kid who's at this school or their
kid plays like baseball or whatever and
just I flash cards 20 Mets every night
as well geez that person wants to become
a senator yeah or or it just has found
how useful that is because people like
it when you remember the name it really
Dale Carnegie and all that yeah wow
that's crazy that's insane I mean it
depends on what you spend your time on
yeah exactly right like what do you do
for a good that's like I like scroll
through Twitter for about 10 minutes and
then pass out my phone in my hand so I
guess I guess someone's using their time
better than me
yeah hey you uh have you heard of Joe
Penna 'he's new movie coming yeah yeah
yeah he made the jump he
the move made the jump from YouTube to
movies and it's and it's a great movie
from what Ron tells us that is it
playing yet I haven't been able to find
okay so it's gotta be around that lay
somewhere I'm sure and I think it is
also hilarious that is and
congratulations for being the better of
the two Arctic themed movies featuring
Matt Nicholson is it hard in the middle
where he plays instruments unlike the
various pieces of wreckage like was
interesting like one congratulations Joe
I've heard great stuff about the movie
and I do want to check it out and I love
Mads Mikkelsen ever since all the stuff
in Hannibal is like just if you have you
guys seen Hannibal the TV show Ren
fuller Mads Mikkelsen plays Hannibal
Lecter and like your first response will
be like certainly certainly nobody is
better than that our boy Sir Anthony
Hopkins as being Hannibal and then watch
this you know Anthony Hopkins could suck
a dick mass Mickelson's bomb he's really
good yeah well here's the thing about
Joe Wright and this is I think what we
think I think the meat of what we're
gonna get into here Joe grew up on
movies we grew up on movies we didn't
grow up on YouTube right in that that's
what we weren't watching grow you know
and in in school you see right through
my segue plan see your segue for the
movie Freddie we're trying to make
movies and you're trying to make movies
and our TV shows or whatever let's let's
be broad non youtube right right mm-hm
well why not YouTube cuz cuz there's
everyone's got reasons yeah well look
here's the thing YouTube every website
has a context right when you look at the
website when that when that context is
established it is hard as hell for that
website to change to wit when you go to
Facebook or cool Facebook is this
Facebook if you'll recall try to be like
we're gonna be the number one platform
for planning events and parties and
stuff and they had all this suffered at
you invite your friends didn't really
quite what we're gonna be photos
Facebook was so bad at switching over to
photos that are cool how much do we need
to spend to buy Instagram we have to
because nobody thinks of Facebook has a
photo thing and the same way instagrams
like Brett and then the same way
snapchat is like hey snapchat could be a
place to watch premium vertical video
cut nobody know I use this
yes this to text my friends and and by
the way not me because I'm not was
useful so when it looks like it's set as
its context it's really hard to change
and YouTube's got set as its context and
its context is personality driven fast
con it's like there's different aspects
to it but for the most part right like
the stuff that when you look at who are
popular YouTube is right now personality
driven individual personality types
right on YouTube that's for the most
part of what it is and even though even
the ones who are doing like content in
it in a really interesting and pervasive
way like like you're like captain
disillusions even then it still is
captain disillusion right in the same
way so if it was Mythbusters it would be
no it's it's it's Adam and Jamie from
Mythbusters there has to be sort of this
personality side in front even even the
even the primitive technology dude is a
silent
you know avatar but he's still in that
right he's his personality is showing
through in his when you turn on the
closed captions mhm and I can give you
another example right like back when
people were still watching this and tons
of this stuff the the hydraulic press
guy most of the comments are about the
guys maniacal laughter in the background
as stuff is getting crushed right so
there's that personality driven and it's
also content that's not a certain
narrative right I think I think that
when we started there was that and there
were people who were experimenting with
that and for the most part now the
narrative that you see is first-person
narrative it's selfies as vlogs you know
so that's a type of narrative and I'm
not I'm not gonna discount it because I
think you know the way Casey nice that
can string together an interesting vlog
is just as much a skill and a skill
that's born from his years doing more
traditional film and TV stuff right and
documentary stuff that's just as much as
a skill as anything else is but it's a
different skill set
yeah right so when we when we got into
it and you what so it was when we talk
about the context of YouTube YouTube is
that and I think it's hard and I think
it's start to solidify around that a
little bit that's kind of what it is you
know yeah in the same way vine the
six-second funny videos right and you're
not getting six second you know intense
emotional stories not that you probably
very difficult to do that in six seconds
but that's what vine was right tick-tock
you know is sort of like the the
evolution of a vine right yeah so I
think that's what YouTube is and I think
that is that not really something you
want to be doing no I don't know I mean
like I think it's fun like right like
there's y'all remember right like I
think that I think for a lot of people
who watch stuff it's you know you're
generally a younger crowd and I think
it's hard for people to sort of get that
arouse or wrap their heads around that
which is the idea of like just because
something is fun doesn't mean that's
something you want to do like as
something won't focus on as a career
right because lots of that's fun to wit
my thousands of very stupid hobbies but
right like this but I think there's it
has to grab you in a different way when
it comes to a career standpoint so what
would you say you want to do for your
career well you know I think honestly
what we want to do is its its its
narrative storytelling its narrative
filmmaking right I think that's
something that we found there something
that I found when we did video game high
school now I will I will note that I
assume a lot of a lot of folks who
there's a lot of folks who do not like
that show and who think that it was
stupid and who think that it was lame
and that we jumped the shark and
everything sucked after that got a chip
on your shoulder
but I think that but I think that's fair
because like right like the way that we
were doing stuff was we're doing a bunch
of fun short stuff and then it was like
here's a narrative thing right and it's
also a narrative thing in the way that I
don't think a lot of people necessarily
expect it right I think when we were
always we always joke that the version
of a game high school that was expected
would be called hardcore gamer Academy
and it basically just be like a but just
like the shorts just strung out right
yeah but you know I think that that but
I think and when you look at that and he
cuz here's why because what I what I
found with that was that like people
still care about that and I think it was
much more gratifying for from a creator
standpoint to be able to like tell a
narrative story arc with characters and
to play in that world to use a food
analogy I've often thought that like a
lot of you know a lot of short videos a
lot of short stuff that on YouTube is
like it's fun but it's like popcorn
right it's like it's funny but there's
always there's another thing and this is
there's always other stuff and there's
always fun viral videos coming out every
yeah every other hour right at this
point is I check out this dance your
other sing take out this vine
compilation' which is like good fun
entertaining but I think from to watch
but I think from the creation standpoint
it's a little bit dismaying because you
put something out you see it it hits and
then cut to a year later and ever nobody
remembers it like occasionally right
there's some that people remember but
like I mean you tell me right when
people come to you and talk to you about
stuff videos they've seen what are like
the top videos that people say for for
things that they loved X right that I
can generate yeah for quarter there's
just a post on the subreddit for clock
blockers oh yeah yeah I mean I don't
know it's it's there's a lot yeah
nerf team portrait yes tiny money like
the most popular videos from a view
perspective last year
well no technical reloads for sure
that's a cool realize by the way we're
gonna be gonna make that sequel it's
it's tack tattoo yeah I mean it's a lot
yeah but like I also feel like but like
but that I feel like there's still more
that you've done that like for the most
part don't necessarily like stick in the
way somebody yeah yeah exactly you know
that and I look at some of the you know
the stuff that we were doing you know on
the on the fray W side and it was like
dude you know I think I think um what
was it called you want to build a house
you don't want to just make like plastic
court tents constant you know to be you
can make some cool tents I love that Ted
but build a house you can live in from a
character standpoint cuz again the most
gratifying thing from a career
standpoint was doing three seasons of
video game high school we're really
getting to dig into and by the third
season being like here's what we can do
with this character and seeing how
people like stick to that and and and
react to that it's less about to me it's
about being able to get away from
yourself as a personality which I've
always hated mm-hm and putting that
attention from the audience side on to
the stuff you're making and onto that
world that you're creating and on to the
characters when people talk more about
oh my god I love this character that to
me is much more satisfying like the when
when we go out and you know and like and
Jimmy gets pulled aside because it was
like Oh Ted you're 10
in high school and like people like I
guess you were you were you were you the
dad that is perfect for me I love I hate
like I don't like being the center of
attention of that stuff why is that why
is that because I mean you know I feel
like a lot of people watching the
content watch do you be the center of
attention and thought that you were
doing a really good job but like that's
what kind of drew them to it yeah no I
Lois I don't I don't discount the fact
that like that's what I think people get
attracted to on in terms of like YouTube
stuff but I think me personally it's
like I again when I was in when I was in
like high school it was like I was a big
camera nerd I was a big editing nerd I
love doing that stuff I left putting my
friends in front of camera doing stuff
with that moreso than being a I just
thought I just never liked the was it a
surprise to you that you ended up kind
of blowing up as a personality like so
that was that ever except I think but I
think here's the thing though I think
the personality that I play is a
character oh yeah right and and but it's
a character too I think a greater extent
than to a greater extent than when you
say of vloggers playing a character
because I've you know I've met you know
we've met a lot of these vloggers and
for the most part they're playing a
mildly amplified version of themselves
right they don't they don't turn the
camera off light up a cigarette decade
boys that you know me like it's like
they are basically that and on camera
they're plussed sitting around doing
head shots and my frigging it's like but
like yeah but the character I'm playing
is a very like it's it's it's a very
Charlie Chaplin ask like it's a goofy
dude who like if you look at the
narrative threads who are a lot of those
old videos it is guy stuck in a
situation that is like out of his it's
like Jackie Chan a little bit right it's
a little bit like in over his head like
oh no like underdog kind of nerdy Jackie
Chan happens to be really tactical like
even that but again like to like dig
into like the specifics of those
character beets right even then they're
looking head then like a aimbot when
like I finally do a bunch of stuff you
get a brief reaction back oh cool
right like oh wow like it's you know
it's not like now I'm the cool badass
like right because that's I don't think
that's interesting was that something
that was that kind of formed naturally
or was was that actually like kind of
preconceived planned and I think how did
that come about actually and there's
always been the back and forth and
collaboration with Brandon
when we were talking about that stuff
okay cuz we were always like I think we
were always like in the situation where
it was like you know what can what is
interesting I think we're always were
gue fee you know I mean so it wasn't
ever like let's do the coolest baddest
baddest ass thing that we can write like
cuz you know I you know I think that if
you if it if it was there'd be a lot
more cool lightsaber fights not by the
way I love cool lightsaber fights so
gonna be robbed but I'm saying we would
have done a lot more cool I'd say her
choreography like like okay it's like
for example I think that like it was
always it was always like how can you
twist it how can have a little bit of a
button to it so it's not just here's a
bunch of dudes getting murdered right
like so one of the first videos that we
did that guy got attention was chrono
trigger right the time freeze yeah do
that one so what's interesting there is
like to me it's like up until the very
last beat of that short it's a well
throughout it is kind of a it's it's
goofy right it's like I'm walking along
I call time out but the very end of it
to me is like what sells that short to
me it's not it's I come around the
corner I do like a you know a cool close
range CQB remember the basics of CQC
like you know a gun thing I shoot a
bunch of guys and then the reaction
isn't like move on tactically you know
like it's yes you know it's like it's
kind of a goofy like kid like sort of
thing and it's that contrast of like
here's a really cool tackle thing it's
like and this guy kind thinks it's cool
yeah I do that you know like it's sort
of a self celebratory thing and that's I
think what what that character is you
know more than anything else it's being
able to is being able to take a step
back from that and anything again like I
will say throughout the course of both
with the fray w air in the rocketjump
era right like there's been a sort of up
there's been experimentation with that
and there's honestly there's time so I'm
like I think that worked well and
there's times where like I don't think
that works as good you know I think that
I look now looking back at some of the
videos I'm like I don't know if that's
it doesn't quite feel right and I don't
know why you know it's right or wrong or
whatever but it's like I just say it
doesn't quite play and I think the way
that yeah some of the older ones do well
you know I think about that a little
more and honestly it's you're just
you're just bringing to life the gamer
archetype you know they that's really
what was happening there you know
imagine you play a video game you scale
Mountain you slay a bunch of dragons and
then you win a bunch of gold and you're
like nice yeah sweet you know yeah
because the react
- that isn't now I'm this like that's
the thing when we were doing feeding him
high school right that was the thing
that we think about a lot which was
everybody for even even to this day they
still get I think the gamer mentality
wrong which is they think cool now that
I'm good at playing a flight sim now I
can be a pilot right it's the last
starfighter
like story arc right well I mean maybe a
little maybe a little bit a little bit a
little bit but but the point is though
now and even for us is like when I'm
playing Battlefield I'm not like cool
let me join the military I'm like cool
I'm good at battlefield cool I'm good at
quake so that was actually really
important to us and we were like putting
together the idea of like kind of how
the world of the video game side of
bidding him high school worked which was
cool they're good at video games that's
it they don't need to be recruited by
the government they don't need to be
real you know and it's like no they're
good at video games and that's what
that's where that line is and because
that is cool and that is something that
is worth aspiring to and so when we when
we when we look when we were looking at
that was like yeah this this person is
just good at video games and they are
fine with that and it's like and the
universe is fine with that the universe
doesn't feel the need to be like and
because you're good at MMOs now you're
gonna do this real things like nothin oh
the real thing sucks we're here for the
video game side of it you know yeah but
yeah I think when we were talking about
sort of those early days a video say
there was it was very much about how can
you do something that's entertaining cuz
again like I think people forget to cuz
I mean you we both kind of grew up on
the special-effects forums of some of
the software packages that we have used
in the past yeah and we've seen a lot of
like let's be honest matrix ripoffs and
we've all been guilty of doing our own
matrix ourselves like the amount of
trench coats that were so trench coats
and airsoft guns that were sold to
teenagers around the airsoft
specifically cheap plastic plastic
desert Eagles my goodness the spike in
sales desert Eagles 1999 air shades from
eBay neo she's you realize how long it
took for me to fight try and find the
phone that clicks out from the matrix
that really and it doesn't click out
like that I kind of added that yeah I
know right anyway but no key a banana
phone as they called it but like right
we've seen a lot of like cool videos
there's a bunch of cool videos and you
know to wit when he's there's a bunch of
very good
viii effects like demo reels that people
put together right half of them are
Video Copilot tutorial specifically the
bullet dodged one but the other half
like some of them are really well done
better than I think anything I've ever
done and then like in and they don't get
passed around people don't sort of build
a sort of thing around it because I
think that there's just like just cool
stuff online just there's really kind of
nothing there yeah it needs to really be
something that you either grasp onto an
emotional level either makes you laugh
either makes you sort of attracts you an
emotional sense or it needs to be just
like so mind-blowing Lee cool that you
have to share it right but but that
thresholds pretty high yeah so I think
for us because I think the secret of our
stuff was the VFX were not the most
intensive effects on the internet right
I think you guys do far far far more
more beautiful more put-together stuff
right we do I always joked when people
are afraid I can feel fix guy I'm like I
feel like I am I'm like I feel like that
would be David Copperfield coming up to
me like you're the best at this trick
the finger train like it's just that
little thing it's not my thumb just
doing the finger trim it's like you're
the best at it's like well no I mean
it's just this little thing that we did
you IIE I feel kind of like a little bit
of an impostor compared to I think real
you know visual effects folks folks who
understand that and who really can do
just anything in that world I think for
us where we put our skill tree points so
to speak what's more in like what's a
funny little situation or what's a funny
sort of character that we can tell and I
think by the way that I think that works
pretty well because you look at right
now you look you look at what is the
state of what is like narrative sketch
comedy yeah on YouTube I would say it
started with guys like they're a comedy
and those guys you know have gone on you
know Donald Glover who was you know
early sketch comedy YouTube days right
who has gone on to actual success SNL
those guys right good neighbor those
guys were gone that's now there's that
world of sort more traditional sketch
translate to online there's kind of like
a little bit our era which was like
digital having effects component taking
advantage of sort of online stuff gamer
terminology sort of that world of sort
of nerd them into it a little bit and
they look at now which is heavily into
the you know world of like referential
topical
kind of humor and instead of a sketch
about it it is you know I think it's
like it is the very excellent stuff that
like someone that's doing like Pro ZD is
doing right but you look at the in terms
of just camera stuff that is it's a
first-person camera it's it's yeah
things a lot of guys come in that
archetype of like you know it's a
character you're playing multiple
character is very minimalistic in terms
of props very minimalistic in terms of
additional stuff and it's funny because
we look at that was like man oh I was
looking at a lot of that stuff II idea
be like yeah like if I was to take that
same idea and do a video I'm like I'm
already I'm already lost cuz I'm already
thinking oh well needs to look like this
and it needs to be this and this it's
like well does it you know it doesn't
really because you see what's being
passed around what people are watching
is like it will if this comes back to I
think what you're talking about with
YouTube I guess defining itself as a
platform because you know like Ian
Chrome or chromium yeah the guy who
looks like a older version yeah yeah
yeah yeah I agree God sometimes I see
something I'm like Jimmy's oh no that's
yeah it's like him and prosy do like
kind of a little bit similar and there's
they kind of tap into that narrative
space without without this like baggage
of having to you know make it look like
well it's a little bit vine influence
right it's a little bit like where the
camera movement itself can't be a true
part of the joke like this at the end
like a little yeah and even though what
is it on evan breen remember he made
like a turtle le turtle oh yeah yeah so
yeah but it's fascinating because that's
that's the topic we were just discussing
over here to where I'm you know we come
from that film background or at least
you know the film aspiration you know
that that's gosh it'll filled that
aspirational film background exactly
well but you know you if you very
frequently get caught up in wanting to
make something look the right way it
because like or suddenly that that that
way of communicating through film is
part of the job you know words like open
but it's funny because it looks like a
blockbuster movie it's like well I'm
like that's that's not a joke yeah
you're right that the texture of film is
something that we both have borrowed on
quite a bit yeah the idea of doing some
widescreen bars as part of the joke and
part the texture and the language of
that visual is part of it and it's the
equivalent and maybe it is the
equivalent of like props and
stand-up routine maybe you can just
stand on stage and deliver jokes I mean
like I think that that even even like
Logan Paul still uses that widescreen
joke pretty frequently you know and so
the thing is that but I think the
problem is is that like it has that
value you know that film background that
cinema language has the value but but it
has the same value as like an art
exhibit you know finding value in the
fact that it has walls and lights yeah
you know it's like okay you're right it
helps box us in but ultimately you still
need something there and the question is
for the audience right it's about it's
about how the modes of consumption right
because I think for a lot of people I
always I try to watch the Oscar
short-films every year and I literally
have the exact same thought process I
guarantee you guys mad - which is you
look at your 34 minutes sure that's a TV
show man right like I think this is this
is my theory nobody really wants to
watch it like if they're gonna commit
they're gonna watch an episode TV mmm so
it takes quite a bit to get someone to
watch a short film right and I think
that like like there was a fun there's a
vine influence there there's a world
world where you're like oh we can just
tell the joke and it's about the
delivery about the person telling it
yeah and that still gets it across and
actually that's more consumable I can
watch it I can get on with my day
I don't necessarily need to feel like
Rach and turn my sound up and I can turn
off that's fine right like it's I think
that there's something something to that
in terms of the way that people shifted
with regards to comedic videos on
YouTube you know and I think that and
I'm not saying that we're a relic of an
age gone by but we're a little bit like
you know a little bit of a relic of ages
gone by because you look again at the
derek comedy sketches and you look at
those and you're like i could see some
of these may be working you know i think
some of these do work still like forever
and ever but then there's also a whole
world from that sketch comedy world
where you're like oh yeah like this
would not really play as well i think
anymore yeah well i mean arguably like
like Gus Johnson
yeah antastic comedian personality actor
on YouTube so what does videos get a
million views most of them get like 500
600 thousand views it's like this guy is
arguably one of the best mm-hm on
YouTube and you think you'd have a huge
audience for it but that's just really
not what
platforms I think it also depends
honestly like right now it was less so
when we were doing it but now more so
than ever is the the influence of reddit
is significant when we started Digg calm
was still a thing and we actually got on
we actually knew some of these Digg calm
right when Digg duck for those of you
who don't know dig calm imploded because
they were revealed that there were
secret cabal's of information brokers
who had trade front page time with each
other and they would basically
round-robin front page em we met some of
those guys hmm and they were like I
remember at the time they were like you
do some V effects for us we can get this
Jedi a-holes video on the digg.com front
page right okay sure I guess really and
then there was like two weeks later
they're like dig calm is no longer a
thing everyone's gone it's like but like
the influence of reddit is a big part of
it right so you look at the guys that
people have heard of they're getting
time on our videos you know because
their stuff is getting posted right peer
technology got a huge boost as our slash
videos are yeah our slash feel so what I
say our I mean our videos I thought oh
you are oh yeah in the way they are ours
has an Internet yeah but yeah right like
so there's people there who right you
can you can point to Oh that they're
getting a big boost and influence from
that and that's a big part of it right
and then for and I think like everything
it comes and goes right they come in
they fall out of favor I was talking to
some of the roosterteeth guys and they
were joking that they're like man it
sucks because like we have stuff I think
that would actually work well I'm like
our videos are like front page reddit
but because it gets posted by our fans
on our subreddit first there's like you
know algorithmically it like doesn't go
to videos because the the main one is on
their subreddit which is like which is
great we love it but it also means that
you're not getting a new group of people
yeah to it so that was like always that
push and pull right and I don't know I
think that that's a day-to-day grind and
I think that you can it's about how much
time you spend working on stuff and what
you want to focus on and less and less
the older I get the less I care about
being like ok cool what's the thing we
have to be doing to be on the front page
of Reddit what's the thing we have to be
doing to stay relevant what's the thing
I could I feel like you're just never
gonna win that eventually is it it's a
tied right eventually that wave
overtakes you what doesn't I think what
doesn't change
is what got us in the movies in the
first place it's I want to focus on
what's a compelling story what's an
interesting way of telling this
narrative how do you craft a character
and put them in a place that leads to
good narrate and like like narrative
consequences what's interesting like to
me that's like a thousand times more
interesting it's more gratifying and
it's not something that you feel like
you it's a craft that you can actually
work at as opposed to what feels like an
industry you have to keep on top of so
would you say you're done with the
internet video game no because like at
the end of the day - it's like it's fun
right think in the same way like I'm not
done with doing this some tricks you
know in the same way you know I I think
that like the foot but the focus is you
have to be honest with yourself about
what the focus is you know I think that
when we were doing you know I we were
unhealthy when we were doing short
videos in order to keep up with that we
were doing one a week and we were
pulling an all-nighter every week I've
my sleep doctor has told me like that
has affected you your sleep is now
affected for the rest of your life as a
result of that Wow and it's like oh cool
was it worth it I don't know right like
in what way well there's this like it's
one it's not healthy it screws with your
sleep schedule I got weird sleep issues
now like I mean one it's a good side
effect but not as a side effect I could
fall asleep instantaneously now like
when I lie down for bed people like oh
you tossin turds like I don't know what
that means
Wow I was going out with I was going out
with a girl and I was like could you
time me how long it takes for me to fall
asleep so yeah sure so she was like we
were like laying down and there's and
then like the next day I like how fast I
fall so there she's like literally you
stopped your sentence I counted to ten
like ten seconds I was holy cow
and it's I would imagine just like
simply knowing you're being timed is
gonna mean oh yeah it's gone right holy
cow consider that a good thing but
there's other stuff too like I get weird
spurts of Thai anyway it's we only again
to my medical history but my point is my
point is it's not healthy to pull an
all-nighter like that I didn't realize
right I didn't realize it would have
like lasting effects though that's
that's mind-blowing yeah I mean I feel
like you've had a few years of good
sleep to try and like yeah recover some
then but I mean we were living wild
though you know easel dust and then
energy drinks yeah Nico and I were
living in a hammock for a while toppling
towers or no but hammocks you see my
hammock stand I did great hammock span
Thanks I do I look fondly upon my time
sleeping in a hammock yeah it was good
sleep they say it's a great way to not
get back soreness it is and also was in
the hammock when an earthquake and it
was a very strange experience but it
wasn't healthy is my point right and
sauce and more than that health it's not
sustainable right right like you're not
gonna just you're not gonna pull an
all-nighter every week until like you
died at the tender age of 33 you know so
do you see do you see rocketjump still
doing Internet videos at all or do you
think no we still do but like but like
where where we've shifted is we're doing
things that we can sink our teeth into a
little so so rocketjump is more of a
like actual narrative production so like
what so like I think that like for
example the last year we did a series
called anime Crimes Division with
someone and that was a lot of fun and
that felt like a thing where i'm like
cool this was this was the mote like
that was the mode where I was like I
felt comfortable at home we were telling
stories in a way you know and again like
there was a lot of very fun jokes we
joked that like that one that show is a
lot like if you let me give you my
theory on stuff which is I think in
order to make something good you have to
love the thing that you're sort of
making you also have to kind of hate it
there needs to be a little bit of hate
in there like in the yes or yin-yang
doubt of it because what that hate gives
you is it gives you a little bit of
perspective on it to be like yeah but
this is this is I want to do it this I
don't like this I want do this better
right as opposed to just wholeheartedly
embracing whatever it is right I think
the best like when I look at fan films I
think the biggest problem the biggest
like error that a lot of fan filmmakers
make us they love their source material
so much that they can't see past it
right I think that's really insightful
and I think like for example what's the
best Batman film Dark Knight right it's
that it's it's the Christopher Nolan run
mmm why is that so good is because if
you look at Chris were knowing Chris for
Nolan's a serious ass film capital s a
serious ass filmmaker he does not mess
around and he is like really intense
about like his war
right you think Christopher Nolan looked
at Batman that was like oh I love this
this debt caped crusader nothing I'll
change nothing I love it it's amazing no
he took liberties with it and he was
like you know what his way of
approaching Joker right everyone was
like when Heath Ledger was cast people
were like [ __ ] this this is gonna suck
Heath Ledger sucks he's up hearts like
this idiot doesn't know what he's doing
but I think Chris were Nolan Harbor just
a little bit of distance from Batman to
be able to be like this is dumb I'm
gonna change this I'm gonna do it this
way instead and what you get is
something that's great right I think
anything that you do you have to have a
little bit so like Amy crimes I'm not
comparing not comparing this at all day
think but my point is and the crab's a
vision for us was like I love anime but
also deep down a little bits like
there's a lot of dumb [ __ ] which is fine
you have to acknowledge it you've
acknowledged that hole so for us that
series is like a love letter to anime
but it's also like a little bit come on
though right this is kind of dumb right
so we we and someone and Riley who was
also in a video game high school sort of
that was that was our that was like the
show that we did last year where I was
like okay this feels like this is an
online thing this is for online you know
it works in the sort of online context
and we're having fun with it and it
feels gratifying to put together a
little choreographed fight scene in the
context of a narrative and it's the
climax of a character arc you know and
it's a lot more fun that way
mm-hmm I think you know especially with
action I think there's a lot of times
action just on its own is kind of boring
oh yeah right like even the best made
actually scenes are kind of boring and
even when people look at like John Woo
and they're like well what about this
it's like no John woos action scenes are
crafted on a character level a hundred
percent yeah the end of the killer is
about two brothers on different sides of
the law coming together finally after an
entire movie to do something righteous
and they're in a church right like
that's the kind of depth that you need
because it's like you know like we could
sit here and do like fun action scenes
all day but it's way more satisfying
when you have in the context the matrix
right when neo decides to not run and do
a fight like you're in the back of your
seat it's like holy [ __ ] he's gonna
fight this in you you built an entire
movie worth of context where why that
fight is important and why defines
intent and then you're on the edge you
see when they're doing it because you
know what servant
and emotion was important on the
character level for everybody involved
in that right and I think that you know
that is a good thing a thousand times
more gratifying and and and I think it's
hard to get that context in uh in in a
short video I think you guys did an
excellent job of doing that for and the
anime car race because right but in in
that case you guys are borrowing sort of
the anime ability to flashback mid
scenes because as you're going it's like
you're getting all of this you know
ridiculous but you're getting all the
character context through the course of
that thing I think that's my favorite
video of anything you guys have ever
done in my opinion that's my favorite
and I have a lot of favorites but I love
that video because it also managed to
get like you're like you come in being a
cool it's gonna be a bunch of like you
know anime so but they just like oh my
god it's a story about a kid and his
father and his father's like it's like a
whole thing there and that you get all
that all the way through which is like
again like that to me that to me is
quintessential good internet video
granted my opinion of that stuff has
changed with regard is is different than
what the opinion of the times is but
that's a good internet video that's
premium Internet you can get regular
Internet videos you can find regular
Internet videos everywhere go to Reddit
go file and scroll through a regular
internet videos but if you want that
premium Internet video those are hard to
find and once you find them he's like
but they're hard to find they are hard
to find like I remember you have like
gems that you trade back and forth your
friends is gem of a video no one's seen
anything like this before now it's like
there's I don't add videos my favorites
anymore kind of the same old thing yeah
you know and I think a lot a lot a lot
of memes yeah a lot of them a lot of
them will lose their context or lose
that kind of what makes them funny in
that moment in a year or two right like
it's less it's it's it's less so I mean
any there's something to be said for the
disposability of vine that what's more
popular is long compilations of these
vines yes right like because again it's
an ease of use thing but it's also like
yeah when I sit down to watch a vine do
I'm expected you just get assaulted
every six seconds by a big visceral joke
a belly laugh and I move on how many
times have you started a vine
compilation' and be like
watch this one yet I think I've watched
this one oh maybe not because you came
in a little bit a little bit forgettable
which is again it's it's like I think I
look at it like comics right like the
like the like in newspapers right mm-hmm
it's like vine was a comic panel it's a
three panel comic right a joke that gets
thrown in there it's not you don't
compare it to a novel you don't compare
it to a movie I mean that's honestly how
I would describe the videos that you
guys made back in the day - yeah like
three-pound comics yeah absolutely yeah
and by the way three pound comps are
amazing it's absolutely so an art form I
think that I think that it's interesting
when I think about comics I think about
you know the og the hero of comics which
would be Bill Watterson right the guy
who created Calvin and Hobbes and when
you look at what he did with the sundae
panels when he looked at the kind of
when he got to the point of editorial
control that he had and be able to be
like I wanna do a full page that's a
beautiful watercolor cuz I know how to
[ __ ] water this is what Bill
Watterson sounds like by the way it's
like listen nervous I'm gonna paint a
big-ass watercolor you're gonna print
that [ __ ] and all the newspaper
publishers were like oh yeah yeah sure
no problem and he was the only one that
could get away with that right but he
could do these incredible art pieces and
and he pushed that comics medium in a
way that nobody was even thinking about
hmm that to me is like that's a guy who
loves that medium and also was willing
to kind of try and push beyond that
medium a little bit and I think about
that a lot because it's like cool I love
doing online videos but it's like I want
to do more with it and I think you can
do more and I think you know obviously
context in the same way that newspapers
as a context for comics has changed and
is you know what it is now and the world
of web comics I think with with online
video I just think a lot of the stuff
that is popular and trends and is shared
is less and less in line with what I
think is interesting as a filmmaker yeah
and everything changes you know yeah
everything changes that again it's not a
good or a bad thing my oath sucks it's
like no no that's just the evolution of
it because we we jumped on the train
during a period of that evolution and
that evolution you know had and we saw a
lot of changes over the course of even
the time that we were there I mean I
remember there was a time when people
were like there will never be another
vlogger anymore and this was pre
jennamarbles people like there's no more
vloggers like every blogging is played
out dog shaycarl got that
Laak it's played out no not true stuff
changes a new generation comes in as
well right different group of kids come
in the group of kids who are watching I
think about things again I've talked
about this before but I think about
things at four year increments mm-hmm
right
anyone who started watching our videos
when we started to tooth 2010-2014 the
year from high school to college at that
point then after a certain point from
college to graduate college those are
very distinct periods of your life if
you know let's not even have to go to
college but graduate high school from
the game high school to end of high
school that's it you're different
right what you were injury interested in
is different right you talk to any
senior yeah hey you wanna do something
that these freshmen are doing they'll
slap you in the face and call you a
doofus
yeah that's what that's how the kids
talk they'll dab in your face and kick
you in the nuts and floss only accept
how many kids is how our dentists not
getting on the flossing thing and maybe
they are maybe you're I mean one was
like a dentist you're right I want to
find please tweet at us please tweet at
us what's your Twitter again we never
use it what it's court or digital we
never use it we that meet we have what
Freddie give me examples of dentists who
have used flossing in embarrassing ways
like I want it dead I just want the
story of someone's like yeah sitting
there he's like oh you've been the yeah
I see you haven't flossed much I'm sure
you do though and that though in that
the fortnight though got do a little
less in the fortnight more in the gums
make sure you get underneath the gum
line to get all the plaque and bacteria
fortnight themed dental floss oh my god
wait really I mean like come on how is
it if there's how how can a two and a
half billion dollar game not like lice
look that up is that bad also you're
Dennis impression is like kind of scary
close to a Hank Hill impression I'll
tell you search for that for all right
dental floss there's the first answers
for tonight dental floss dance no guys
guys guys we just found it we found it
billionaires in a thousand airs you know
anyone in the American the American
Dental Association we need to get him on
the phone right now yes we got ourselves
the next billion dollar
yeah oh my gosh dental only dentists
everyone's gonna be flossing all the
kids and then I mean they got like maybe
two months before apex takes it over
then we gotta hop on that fast get on
that train guys do you guys have any
legs I love it I've played a little it's
fun but do you think it's gonna stick
around here's the problem Nico if you
when you play for tonight the first time
if yous if someone asks you that
question you'd be like ah no you go I
don't bet on horses I ride them that's
got to be chiseled on your gravestone
right there we go I'm quoting that
that's a good one Sam just saying who
knows who knows is the answer is a new
video game every year that like here's a
pop G it's this here's a question for
you so this is an interesting question
so all of our anti all of the game types
that we know and love now Bal Royale
right they're based heavily in the fact
that they were modded my community right
so dota and also dough the chess now
right have you heard about the other
chess holy [ __ ] man since having to it
sounding it's the it's the dodn't
variant that's sweeping the world um all
right they're all based on modding
community yeah right
so like Bal Royale type was because
player unknown was doing it for ArmA and
then went on to do it for the zombies
h1z1 right that's a mod and also like
minecraft that was a mod like Bowery I
was like a mod mode and then Hunger
Games mods right mhm
we even go farther back team fortress is
a quick mod counter-strike was um was a
half-life mod yeah have fun yeah right
so modding clearly ill is a way to for
people to experiment with new game types
in a environment that is not like you
know that allows them to experiment
allows them to evolve it right yeah
exactly so now that there's but I think
modding is on downturn there's less and
less people that are playing PC games
which is kind of necessary
modding there's fewer and fewer people
who there's fewer developers who open up
their games in that way so where are
these new game types gonna come from if
that if that life spring is getting
plugged up well gosh that's a great
question I mean gmod still has a solid
community that's for sure and I mean
minecraft obviously he's a huge
community I mean yeah minecraft mods'
like gosh nobody mentions unity unreal
like so you think that people need to go
down so game engines will come up to the
point I think that's I think probably
the real solution here cuz you know
arguably they're already at that point
unity yeah you can get that in unreal
for free and it's like that's like I
mean that's kind of the same amount of
work that goes the same amount of work
that went into making the Battle Royale
mount mod for ARMA 3 like is not much
different than just hopping into like
unity or anything and just kind of
building up so really what it is so
really what it is to me it sounds like
those engines need to have very robust
easy to use like multiplayer stuff right
because like that'sthat's how it works
with you know the asset store yeah and
it's like you just literally can bring
in a first person shooter module that
handles all your camera controls and all
your stuff like that and gives you your
your rudimentary weapons and items and
you then you can just tweak you so
that's that's where that's where the new
sandbox is yeah that's interesting I can
see that oh yeah I mean it's part I
don't I don't think that fully answers
the question but it's in a way it's kind
of like the modding community it's like
it it the door swung open yeah in a much
wider way you know yeah I feel like the
too big or honestly I feel like the
biggest thing that we've seen change in
video games in the past year or two two
years here is learning to give your
character's life some stakes yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah in multi in the
multiplayer content right we're talking
about this I agree with that yeah yeah
like learning to make figure out a way
to make their make drama behind your
death because I mean I've talked about
this before but the gameplay of the
gameplay of a game like halo we can just
run and I respawn run and die respond or
yeah or Call of Duty like those are
literally just go in and spar and see
how many people you can punch before you
get punched yeah and you maybe punch one
or two and the older you get the less
more the closer that is to zero that is
the one right now
think of an army where the soldiers just
running in Sami people they can shoot
before they get shot right right that's
not how a tactic s' work right and you
can't have tactics in that situation you
can have tactics there's no value to ya
when your value to your life
yeah and battle royale modes brought
that they brought value to your
character's life life that you're
playing for there's and there's a
gradient right because like when you
talk about Daisy it was on the far
extreme because you lose everything
you've invested X hours everything is
gone that's the far end extreme bow
rails I call you lose 40 minutes if
you're waiting to the end but you're
starting afresh your death is permanent
in this within the context of this game
time yeah right and arguably that's why
we spent so much time playing escape
from Target yeah yeah scuzz tarkov
actually does that
well RPG with the little permadeath a
little bit in there all of a sudden
becomes really like oh [ __ ] like I gotta
I can't die yeah well you can't do
realistic gun simulation that's true if
you're not gonna simulate the value of
life that's true that's true because
because if you because people do act
like I remember hearing about talking to
some of our friends who have been in the
[ __ ] so to speak and they're like oh
yeah it's you don't just rush in it's
because you don't want to die yeah
you're right
yeah here's the thing though there's one
other one last element which tarkov
doesn't manage to do and that is the
element of deciding to not kill people
that's because right now all these games
are simply like oh the reward is 100%
killed this person yes exactly and I
still have never played a multiplayer
game that gives you the option to shoot
anyone
and then also given it gives you like
really good reason to not do that - yeah
that's a good point
because I feel like I mean or maybe
that's just like people right it's like
dude everyone just secretly wants to
just murder everyone who knows but you
know I just but no that's a good point
there is no that well but it's a reward
system right a rewards in like even in
tarkoff it's like I could it's the risk
reward is too great it's like cool I
could not kill this person or if I kill
them I get their dog tag or whatever
equipment they have and that's worth it
versus that and shooting you in the back
and I lose everything right yeah why
wouldn't and in it maybe in a basic
sense it's because the games you know
they're not we're not dealing with games
programmed to really get that far
because effectively killing someone is
action and not killing them is in
action and you don't play games for in
action so I mean yeah I don't know where
that goes all I know is that I'm waiting
for somebody to make a king of the hill
video game based in the armor mod I'm
waiting for someone to make a king of
the hill game based on the king of the
hill universe that's like hangers-on
town got it yep collect propane get a
hell would be awesome yeah the hill
would be good for those not familiar
with King in the hill it's awesome ARMA
3 Monty should check it out but
basically it's uh it's basically a game
where there's like a huge city and then
there's multiple spawn points that are
miles away from that city where that
battle zone is and you have responds and
but but the way you get to that cities
especially cool because you're basically
buying and purchasing choppers jeeps
vehicles and so the journey to the
battlezone is half the fun
game and this king of the hill I'm
trying to think where was the first king
of the hill mod I'm sorry game type I
think ARMA 2 mm I think it's myth the
fallen Lords really yeah I like well
actually they're tribes tribes tribes
tribes internet historians got to back
us up on this one tribes basically you
would spawn in and there would be like
multi why is he right there be like you
know these carriers drop ships that
would hold up like five to ten people
y'all hop in Shh you fly over to the
fight um yeah so that is that kind of
it's it's the shuttling of players into
battle but I mean what I think makes
that fun though is that you there's not
like you don't spawn behind someone or
people are spawning near yeah it's like
the only way people are getting to this
battlefield is by like like some other
means of like physical transportation
transportation yeah yeah yeah I guess
the king of the hill king of the hill
would have liked pickup trucks yeah yeah
he's throwing bombs like lawn chairs
lawn chairs
just like fences fence lots of fences
you build fences Suns just a really
unauthorized king of the hill King a lot
the longer your character stays alive
the worse the sunburn gets
very good um why don't you guys make a
season four uh vGHS why do we not make a
season for a vGHS uh well so there's a
whole list of reasons but the long story
short is I think that the character
story we want to tell and that arc was
about high school and high school
romances like the thing that we wanted
to kind of really get across which is a
feeling that it's hard to like I think
if you never experience it in high
school like you will if you know I
usually this it's like it's the idea
that like you know people are their own
thing and just because you want
something from someone at that time
doesn't mean they're gonna go for right
that's why Brian and Jake do not get
together and it's the story is not about
Brian finding the love of his life
because she it's high school she
probably isn't and she has her own
aspirations and dreams and she's going
to pursue those and that's the time to
you know right that's high school is the
time to do it it's not that he finds the
love of his life it's that he finds
friends because we start with him in
season one as a total loner friendless
loser who's getting bullied by arguably
bigger losers than he is right but the
ending is him finding friends and
finding that family and that is that arc
of that character that's the story from
beginning to end of who that person is
right it's in the same way that Harry
Potter finds his family at the end of it
it's not that Harry Potter finds a hot
girl and totally gets to make out with
her at the end of every end of Harry
Potter it's like no it's a he has a
family and he has friends and that's the
arc that we want to tell for him and and
also I think for her it's also one for
Jennie it's about reconciling with you
know sort of the pressures of of her
mother and then becoming you know
becoming her own person in that way and
understanding that aspect about her so
from a character story standpoint it we
told the story that we want to tell now
there's not to say that there's not
stuff that we couldn't still not do in
the universe one we did a story break
we did a were part of the max fund that
work on story break we did a bonus
episode for okay what if okay let's say
we have to do season four what would we
do
what would the character conflicts be
and then the one that we came out with
will we came up with a book okay the fun
kind of sit
esque story that could work in if we
continued it would be like around Jimi's
character around Ted and we're oh here's
what it would be it would be Freddy
Ted's father had a kid had another kid
and then Jimmy's next of Kin's and now
he has to raise a child in high school
again it's it's fun it's like kind of
goofy but it's not like like it's not
character story in the sense that you
know we were it's a very fun episode
because we get into it we get into like
a lot of jokey stuff in terms of like
what could happen but that's like the
story wanted to tell and I think when we
look at that universe - because Emma was
a hydrogen video in college one is I
think you have to be I think you have to
be true to how like obviously we're
playing in the fantasy world with with
with professional video games and that
was a thing I think there was a big
distinction with being in high school a
lot of people like oh it's a sci-fi show
like no it's not
it's a fantasy show that has a lot of
you know sort of sci-fi elements to it
but if it's mostly a fantasy show it's a
show it's a show about what if because
the real world of videogame professional
view game playing kind of sucks right
like it's you have to be part of a crew
you have to be in a house and you're
training you're getting up early you're
working out then you're playing League
for eight hours and you're training with
your teammates and you all go to
tournaments and the tournament prize
spots are okay and you live in the
middle of Utah because that's where the
fast internet is and that's your life it
and like cool like you know but that's
not a fan the fantasy is it's Harry
Potter right it'll be like is if there
is if wizards were like okay but magic
is like really segmented and you can
only do it in these government jobs no
it's like the fantasy is it's a giant
you know ridiculous over-the-top world
and that's what we were portraying so
there's a lot of stuff I think we would
still want doing that so again we're the
world of TV in the world of movies the
gears turn slower than YouTube like we
have a animated show pitch that we are
working with titmouse the guys who did
Metalocalypse whole bunch of stuff cool
and we've been going around with that
like so there's there's versions of that
story that we want to tell but then I
think any additional version has to be
one true to the world of video games
which is video in college like let's be
honest if your college a
to your coach when you look at the look
at the pro teams like the guys who are
coaches are like like 20s right like
they're like they're old you're old when
you're college age when it comes to
video games so it doesn't make sense to
be like oh we're in college it's also
like I don't think that there's like the
car you have to think about the type of
story you're gonna tell right I think a
high school story is a perfect story of
like coming of age and discovering
yourself and and and and finding friends
and figuring out who you are in this
world whereas college you look at the
famous source stories of that it's less
about that it's less about you're not
coming of age necessarily you know in
college to the I'm just off the top my
head I'm like what do you have you have
Porky's you have like the you know the
the comedies of the of the 80s and
they're set in college but then like
high school you have to go you have your
Harry Potter's you have all your formula
they've sort of Heroes Story types of
stuff and fantasy like I'm end up in
that at that age rape so it's like
college you're just like I just don't
think there's anything interesting there
whereas I think when we thought we
looked at high school right there's a
lot of interesting things we want to
explore and for people who you know have
stuck along with reading in high school
and saw season two and three there's
stuff we get into that is like about
high school like for example one of the
big arcs in season three was the death
of parent right and how weird that is I
had that happen to me I experienced that
in high school mad experience at in high
school like where you have someone that
you know and their parent dies and like
it's wild you know I don't know if you
guys do you guys have that in high
school it's it's a strange experience
because it's like it's you think in high
school everything's and you know you're
it's fun it's invincible and then Sears
the real world and life coming in and
Chu in a way that you don't expect and
it's interesting it's just interesting
and we really want to explore that in an
episode of a game high school right and
the eeo the idea of like the
temporariness of teen romances in high
school and how it can seem like the most
important thing and how like when you
look back at it it's like oh that was
fun and it was like a little bit of it
wasn't that important really or wasn't
that mean the meaning of it was way more
when you were a kid than you are when
you look at it now there's a lot of
stuff that you can explore in that high
school context so I still we still want
to live in that world I think it's much
more fun than the idea of like high
school and the idea of that sort of at
that time period being like a
transitional time for people is really
fun so we have ideas and I think a lot
of them are tend to be more in line with
I think a little bit
in line with what the way the other game
Proust probed gaming has become now so
we have ideas for continuation stuff
that still play in the universe but I
think when it comes to those main
characters especially sort of Brian J
those main characters I think that's
that story is told and not to say that
they can't show up later and be sort of
fun color in sort of continuations of
eating them high school but I think from
a character story standpoint I think
that that's that's where we're happy
with where we ended up with it gotcha
what's the biggest challenge you're
facing these days to trying to get more
shows off here's the heart here's the
biggest challenge folks we did a lot of
stuff on YouTube we did a lot of stuff
web series wise we did we set records
for a crowdfunding we did a web series
and nothing Bubble Bobble who cares
nobody gives a [ __ ] yeah that's what it
is sorry here's here's here's here's the
hard lesson that I've learned over the
last few years which is context is
everything if if we decided to split off
back in 2012 let's say and there's a
alternate version of us right and and
they're also having a podcast right now
alternate versions of us where we all
decided to go down the direct-to-dvd
horror movie route which we were all
embroiled in back in round 29 to 2009
2010 and we decided to all just be like
[ __ ] it let's make movies feature films
that are cheap and can turn a profit
those alternate rally versions of
ourselves are having a better career in
Hollywood right now than us because the
fact is when people look at your past
work they say they look at ourself know
you guys know something used to what
YouTube the thing where that guy
recorded a video of a dead dude Oh
YouTube the thing my kid watches and
it's like there's ifwhat PewDiePie and
he's like what yeah the Stig was never
left this thing was never left so
anything you've done in this context
nobody cares because at the end of the
day there's only two things that matter
in doing stuff in the traditional
Hollywood sense which is did you make
anyone any money did you win anybody any
awards mhm and again right in the
traditional sense people don't do the
traditional sets like well but like it's
easier said to be just don't do it
traditionally because fundamentally
there's a lot of things when you get
into the details of it that still tie
you to some degree of traditional like
approach for example if you said don't
do it traditionally well you could go
anywhere cool where are you getting
actors because like it or not every
actor knows that money is in Los Angeles
that's how they can make a living they
can get a commercial they can get roles
in Los Angeles so the Los Angeles is
kind of where actors need to be so if
you're going anywhere else and you want
to use any actor you're either pulling
from your local population who if
they're good they probably got into Los
Angeles or you have to fly them from out
from Los Angeles which is just an
additional cost that you're just paying
now in order to handle that right so it
is and there's a lot of stuff like that
right screw it's you know sure you can
shoot anywhere but crew cast a lot of
these sort of like the fund you can't
make a movie without I mean you know you
need movies for the most part you need
people and so those those sort of modes
are sort of like class set and yeah you
could again Tyler Perry has done this to
an amazing extent right he's set up in
Georgia and he's like I'm doing my own
thing I'm making my own studio in
Georgia I'm doing elle's and he was able
to do that right
he also made he also before he did that
he made a bunch of movies that made a
bunch of money and we're profitable so
it's that's the that's the hard part
right now is that where I feel like I
always feel like we're in between we're
in between the world like I feel like I
have more experience behind camera and I
have more experience like directing
actors and doing that work than most
people walking into Sundance and selling
their movies but that experience is
meaningless unless it's applied in that
context and that sort of other other
ways so in a weird way it feels like one
more time about doing a feature film or
talk about TV even though we did like a
couple of Hulu shows right but you did a
couple whose shows but the way that that
world works is like too bad you're not
you know some name some known showrunner
and you didn't get tons and tons your
shows and get all the Oh 4/5 seasons
you're not known in that way it's harder
for you to put yourself out there like
that so when we talked about even
feature films it's like nobody's walking
up to us and be like here's a movie we
want you direct that's like no no no no
no you as far as as far as those people
are concerned we're unproven entities so
in the way it feels a lot like we're
back at square one and having to prove
ourselves we're back it's were one with
actual experience and I think that's
helpful right way more so than anyone
else that if you know if we were coming
in you to it but it does feel like we
got to kind of prove ourselves all over
again
I'm sure you guys have sort of felt that
a little bit to it yeah right which is
maybe kind of what's kept us doing
YouTube is because part of me doesn't
like the idea of going out there and
trying to like scratch it from the dirt
again you know yeah I kind of wanted I
can do whatever I want here right right
to it and agree you know obviously I
keep the lights on but I can make videos
and I can be my videos I can control
when they come out and what they're
gonna be and my budgets aren't big but
at the same time I still have plenty of
resources that would otherwise be
expensive starting from actual from
actual scrap yeah and maybe like I look
back at our past experiences doing
long-form content you know the ones that
stand out are rush battlefield rush
right and lifeline and they both had
their variety of challenges but rush was
honestly a bunch of fun um yeah
challenge with rush was at the
battlefield IP right which fell apart at
the last second that's why it's inspired
by battlefield it was also yeah it's
just a constant strain on the production
from from day one well cuz at the end of
the day you're like it or not right
you're secretly doing a commercial yeah
because that's the the brand world which
has evolved over the years but that's
what that ends up being and so you're
still beholden to those needs and right
and their and their requests which
oftentimes has very little to do with
they want to sell a video game they
don't want to make a cool movie exactly
it's hard to put your months if not
years of work at the whims of some
marketing director that's Sunday's world
yeah that's fair um but generally
speaking that project was still solid
and I enjoyed it quite a bit and I think
the end product was good - mm-hmm
lifeline was a bit of a different story
it still has its you know it's moments
but life one was very much like in the
traditional system right like really
turned me off to the traditional system
I don't really have a desire to go back
to doing that mm-hmm even though I have
a desire to make movies and shows I just
not like that yeah we just
I mean we've said the story on a podcast
before but really we got burned yeah the
camera Union wouldn't let us touch the
cameras and we're like it's ya Tube
channel you know YouTube and they're
like nope yeah yeah it's so sour yeah we
saw that we saw that on dimension 404 -
it
- right like an any and at the end of
the day like right like I I joined the
editors guild in order to edit right and
there was one of those things where it
was one of those things where I was like
you know I think even since Aki had to
join the sound editor skilled as well
you know so you know I think I think
there's there's always gonna be it's a
question of how you want to play ball
and and I think what I found though is
it all comes down to money if something
is expensive depending on your right
point of view but like if something's
expensive the more expensive it gets the
harder it is for you to do your own
thing yeah the tree bird is the more
likely you are to do your own thing but
then it's cheaper so you have to kind of
be scrappier in that sense so when I
even talked about you know feature films
we're in that mode of like okay it's got
to be cheap it's got to be like a one
location kind of thing which is where I
think Joe mr. guitar man to go to bring
this all the way around brilliant right
brilliant in being like cool his movie
out the gate is a what is one that he
can manage it's one that from a from a
cost standpoint is is is workable right
it's not a big sprawling epic whatever
it's like no no make a movie that get a
base hit right make a movie that is
solid that can make its money back that
is what sets you up to be able to
continue that career right you don't go
up there and just swing for the fences
on your first time outside get a base
hit prove that you can do this and then
you can find that later but that's again
that's a journey and that's a process
and that's one that you know I think for
I think that for me it is why I got into
making videos and movies and stuff in
the first place and the taste of what
because I think I've had I've had the
taste of what it could be
whereas I think when we got to like
video game high school season three and
even like the Hulu shows I was like oh
it can be like this now with caveats
with parameters but we got to that point
where like yes it can actually feel
loose in a way that you know we like and
and and you know I wasn't necessarily
turned off by it there were parts where
I'm like this doesn't make sense and I
don't like this I understand what the
logic is and that logic may be applied
10 years ago but it certainly doesn't
make sense now but you know again I
think to me it was part of the challenge
of it and something that I I kind of
want to get into you know yeah
definitely do you think movies the
movies that you imagined yourself making
back in the 90s or so what movies are
now
are they still assuming movies are well
I think movies as a whole changed right
I think what you see a lot of right now
is you see a lot of sub five million
dollar movies which is very very cheap
and I'm sure people there you know
people are unfamiliar with films stuff
like five million dollars it's a lot of
money saying then and then five million
dollars is not even a single at this
point what half of an epic game of
Thrones is that 13 an episode right five
million dollars gives you Bruce Willis
for five days yeah exactly exactly and
then by the way and if you're shooting
only with Bruce Willis or five days and
it's uh and it's you're shooting at the
movie pace the breakneck pace of two
pages a day that's ten minutes of Bruce
Willis so like but yeah like like like I
think that movies changed you see a lot
of sub-5 stuff it's arguably is probably
pretty easy as far as like you know the
scale of difficulty it's like it's
workable to do some five because you
know it's like as long as it's hitting
checking certain boxes you can make your
money back on it yeah all the very good
stuff that a 24 is putting out sort of
in terms of like you know a distribution
like that's that's all kind of in that
category and then even them even stuff
like get out right which which started
off as a very very cheap movie that
they've kind of tested right the entire
bloom house sort of horror model is that
it's like make it cheap test it out and
then if it seems like it's good then
kind of put my it's a very sort of
conservative approach to it or you see
giganto ten polls rights Marvel movies
it's out the DC movies and the middle of
it has sort of fallen out in the middle
of it which which is a bummer because
you know what lived in the middle of it
Nicholas Cage movies Nick Cage movies
you had also lived in the middle of it
and films The Matrix right like that
that was the world of the middle then
like you know and there was a district
nine right like though that whole world
like it's about twenty to fifty million
that kind of middle ground it's just
it's hard to justify it it's hard to
make that happen you know I think the
only people who even get close to that
are like the Coen brothers right people
super established in that world are able
to kind of do stuff in that world
because they're they're using the best
actors in the world you know and and
they have the reputation of that but uh
I think that middle ground
appeared which is which is a bummer
because who knows if it's coming back so
then I think the answer is right that
you either adapt to it or right I think
have to adapt to it anything you have to
be like okay cool what is what can you
do four five right and then even like
the raid right the raid the raid and
raid - that's the answer that's one of
the answers to it which is do it like
they did in the raid right John wick is
more expensive but ken Reeves helps in
terms of justifying that expense if you
don't have cantle Reeves you can do John
wick up to level two did John wick but
that's let's get a son team
let's build relationships in that sense
you know even even though even for his
Dead Pool to an extent right it was kind
of that is still in that Miller so it's
not totally dead yet but you have to be
smart about how you approach it hey yeah
yeah but you know I
yeah I think that the whole the world of
John Woo action epics in that that we
grew up loving are harder and harder to
find well and your faucet you're finding
them elsewhere you'll find them in Korea
you're finding them in Southeast Asia
those types of movies yeah yeah to wrap
up this podcast okay
what's the coolest hobby you've picked
up this past year cool Asami have picked
up this past year so I've gotten real
and so I have been really into like
magic and I think you've seen some of
this stuff in fact yeah back in the day
little car correct stuff like that I've
gotten more and more into it it's a lot
of fun it's really interesting that the
sort of the world best sort of like the
infighting world ends because there's
definitely the feeling of like there's
old guns like og machines who are like
yeah dude this is corny and they're
doing stuff we're like I don't know
about that and then there's sort of the
new guard magicians who are much flash
here and like hipper and so it's very
much like Arrested Development a little
bit is interested but it's interesting
you know so we do love like magic stuff
and getting into that is it cool now
nico that depends on your definition of
the word cool it's cool it's cool it's
cool if you if you strut it out and make
it cool
but yeah just sort of just getting back
into the into that
as a hobby I want to get into some some
race droning look at my boy with my boy
Niko here mm-hmm
we may get into that but that one was
newbie drone cinema desk for you oh
thank you oh my God thank you so much
yeah so yeah basically that I mean look
doing hobbies people always wonder
because they think a lot of stuff that
we do now is off camera right it's like
when you're writing like with the end of
last year we fished up a script for a
studio and it was like that's I can't
say [ __ ] about that I came I came and
say well I shouldn't say with studio
this right like it's I came and said do
that like it's just we did a script and
guess what script writing is it's not
tweeting about it it's not right it's
not to doing videos of it so we've been
busy that's not visible mmm again the
most visible thing we've been doing
there's our podcasts so story break
which is where we try to break a story
in an hour and then dungeons and daddies
where we pretend to be dads and where
can one find these podcasts why the
Google Google search the story break or
dungeons and daddies is that dungeons
and yeah yeah story break is just google
it it's um Apple it's on Spotify it's on
all everyone's favorite if you're if
you're listening to this you probably
you probably are in an app or I know
find a way to get there dungeons and
daddys if you google it make sure you
add a podcast to the end of that search
just dungeons that podcast happens when
you search for normal dungeons and and
daddies you get a lot of search results
there's a lot of hits on that one a lot
of hits a lot of hits oh boy it's gonna
be difficult for us to climb up over the
SEO that's already there for dungeons
and daddys but that one's that dungeons
guys calm or any again all do all the
usual podcasts up that's the problem
somebody has a good podcast where you
say that podcast sorry this is a tangent
you're reminding me
do you still sit on URLs are you still a
URL Parker you still go on like Network
Solutions comments and by sick URLs
hoping somebody will buy them from you
and also have you ever sold one I've
never sold all my girls are dumb what's
your most prized URL
god this is years ago I haven't done
this in a while what did I have
Oh erect oral college calm because it's
like you know and I thought what I
wanted to do with it was to make a
website and then it's like dongs and
then it's like the more quotes
right as they win on election night the
dogs turn red and blue so no one wanted
that one hmm and I didn't do that
obviously
well yeah who's your idea so I'm gonna
steal it for me so erect aural college
is out there I think that would expired
I let that one go into the sunset I'm
like it's not it's time what about you
do you have any good you are else no I
know no once once they added dot pizza
and [ __ ] it just became not cool anymore
everyone's got one
everyone's got exactly the right one
everyone's got like cool dot cool party
dot business I'm just happy we got
corridor digital without the hyphen in
the middle like Penny Arcade it's like
penny - arcade that's like man why do
they have a - you can get penny arcade
without - and like we actually found the
guy that had corridor digital comm which
is like for this like one corridor of
businesses like the Midwest and like we
buy it for me I was like mmm I think I
might use it like 10 grand if you want
it's like I'm not gonna buy for 10 grand
it's just a card just goes at the end of
our email address yeah dude calm slash
corridor and then he dies later a guy
who works as like at like an Internet
networking place was like hey you know
I'm a big fan of the channel I just
wanted to go check if court or digital
was available and it was so I bought it
for you so here it is it's like oh wow
like I let it expire we said I'm at ps4
as a thank you that's the that's the
real currency of this modern age ps4 is
an Xbox ones that's cool holy [ __ ] so
that's really nice of him and now you
can go to corridor digital calm and get
all your merch you can stuff all your
videos just live it there go into your
settings and make sure you set that as
your homepage so that every time you
open that Chrome you getting the big ol
eyeful of the Nico yeah and the Sam
yeah you guys should hire me to do all
your plugs I'm good at that yeah yeah
let's do it after this plug me up baby
yeah yeah cool Freddie well thank you so
much for coming out yeah thanks for
having me man always a good time I was a
good chat
always a good slam jam let's make a
tactic Tech TAC - cool reloads - wait
quick brainstorming session go 30
seconds all right so I was thinking
might be really cool if we're
revolutionary soldiers and our reloads
aren't uh like super slow it's like a
prequel really fancy fancy so it opens
with like a little portal and two cops
get thrown out into the middle of the
you're still fighting in a museum you're
still wearing the same costumes yeah
yeah the jorts words or it's a situation
where it's like that but we just were in
a situation where everything can be
reloaded like a staple gun say poles
then maybe it's like I'm thirsty and I
neither like but reload the water my cup
no you have to read you have to do that
you lose that does water cool you got to
attack reload in the middle of it where
we we've turned the whole water cool
upside down and you swap out for one but
you keep the other one like nearby yeah
water coolers pretty good just reloading
everything yeah I mean loading
everything oh man that's pretty good at
some point I'm holding control you're
hitting arm that's so good yeah just
doing real is Buster's reliving
everything yeah I like that that's
really good
yeah web page yeah I buy it okay yeah so
you can get a blunderbuss or like an old
revolutionary it's just like hanging on
the wall or something yeah yeah yeah I'm
just having was your staple guns
batteries triple-a batteries you have to
do you have to do with a battery one
it's like a light it's like reloads you
screw it out you dump the batteries and
then he's cooked and I just cut to like
searching for E and there's nothing and
then it cut to like Amazon double-a
batteries and I just hit wait and then
the guy comes to go thank sign for the
package and then you continue it's like
a hard pause
the middle of it where you have to order
some form and I'd be great I think you
just straight break the fourth wall
there's a part we have to reload the
card on the camera this is a solid ass
ID employes I think I think that's
really good so it may seem like we just
made that up but actually been thinking
about this like a couple months say that
it's good I'm in just name the time in
the place and the Amazon Prime account
just watch out though leave enough ideas
for video number three is that so no you
got you got put it all out in the field
every time everything you get a tactical
three loads are can we keep it serious
going at what point is become like fate
of the Furious you know they tried so
hard on that one didn't I mean of the
time you know that's jacked up about
Hobbs and Shaw know isn't one of them a
villain last time I checked shot killed
Han
excuse me shot killed Han who's Han uh
drifter the drifter our boy Oh shot
killed it what an [ __ ]
how did he kill him he murdered him in
his car with he's on yet but the gun no
more be a car on car I think it was God
on face Wow he murder and then I almost
it no joke the end the last basket first
one it's like you're welcome at our
table and he's sitting and eating eating
food sharing a meal with with Dom I
almost walked out of the theater I was
like my boy I would not stand for this
he got murdered by this guy it's like
dude
Nico if I murdered Sam would you ever
let me have dinner with you after that
maybe maybe one final dinner yeah it'd
be like I purposely make it really bad
food just saying it wouldn't be a
barbecue wouldn't be a good-looking
barbecue though no Freddie welcome a
table will be full Corona boy hey Niko
I'm sorry I murdered your friend Sam but
forever we'll just eat barbecue now the
word friends
is it the muscles those muscles
transcend all boundaries including those
when you kill your friends maybe next
time all right thanks thanks guys
good times with good friends that's what
I like to have in a podcast if you guys
want subscribe to corridor cast here on
YouTube it's a good decision for your
life it'll make it better you can also
listen to this podcast anywhere podcasts
are found spotify google podcasts or
whatever it's called itunes whatever
else is out there
trust me the corridor cast is there also
go check out Freddie's podcast dungeons
and daddies and story break story break
isn't as fun to say as dungeons and
daddys anyways yeah go say hi for us
tell him that he's a cool dude alright
thank you for watching everybody
subscribe